mir ist ganz egal ob der winde liebes
oder um das schlimmes getan hat
für mich ist neutralität immer ganz
wichtig für mich ist dass herr meyer
herr müller herr schulze
herr bernd ist jva beamter im größten
offenen vollzug europas in bielefeld
senne
das hört sich ja nicht so begeistert
dann warum sagen sie das ganze richtig
also nicht verzweifeln meiner vorne
kommen sagen hier ich hab da ein problem
früher war mein fahrlehrer nun kümmert
er sich um gefangen hört ihnen auch zu
jawohl für das ist vielleicht auch ganz
wichtig dass nicht dieses von oben herab
sondern dieses auf einer ebene sein und
bespricht man über gott und die welt und
nicht nur über knast im offenen vollzug
bekommen die gefangenen schritt für
schritt mehr freiheiten die beamtinnen
und beamten unterstützen dabei
wir sind nicht dafür da die jungs noch
weiter zu bestrafen wir sind dafür da um
die jetzt hier zu versorgen egal was sie
gemacht haben egal wie blöd man das
findet aber im endeffekt wir müssen es
hinkriegen dass sie draußen wieder klar
kommen in unserer normalen welt unserer
abteilung von herrn bernd und seinen
kollegen wir sind besonders ältere
inhaftierte untergebracht weil kannst du
belegt werden dass frische unsere
chancen herren fast 1600 haftplätze gibt
es insgesamt
[Musik]
eine eigene wäscherei und viele
arbeitsplätze auf dem gelände
wer aus dem geschlossenen in den offenen
vollzug darf wird intensiv geprüft die
jva-leiterin interviewt jeden einzelnen
am ende auch persönlich
[Musik]
verurteilt lebenslänglich wegen mordes
und trotzdem tut mir heute die
entscheidung für den offenen vollzug
sie sind jetzt relativ frühzeitig in
offenem vollzug gekommen die ganzen
entscheidungen sind auch die gutachter
sind ja alle in der hinsicht dass der
offene vollzug für sie jetzt die
richtige
vollzugsform ist die art der tat spielt
bei dieser entscheidung keine rolle wir
haben jegliche
straftaten hier im offenen vollzug es
kommt drauf an ob derjenige der hier in
offenen vollzug kommt geeignetes für den
offenen vollzug das heißt keine
missbrauchsgefahr das heißt also die
begehung einer straftat muss
ausgeschlossen werden und derjenige darf
nicht fliehen das sind die beiden
kriterien die ausschlaggebend sind für
eine unterbringung im offenen vollzug
und das kann jeder inhaftierte egal
welche straftat er verbüßt selbst
menschen die mit lebenslang bestraft
oder für die eine sicherungsverwahrung
angeordnet wurde und auch einen zu
lebenslanger freiheitsstrafe verurteilt
da muss ja wieder auf das leben in
freiheit vorbereitet werden der übergang
wieder in die freiheit kann nur über den
offenen vollzug laufen und das sollte
meines erachtens für jeden inhaftierten
gelten egal ob lebenslänglicher
sicherungsverwahrter oder strafgefangene
jeglicher couleur
mit denen hat auch der beamte rethmann
in seiner abteilung zu tun er ist der
sogenannte sport beamte
mit einer berechnung umsetzen und 30
fußball statt um 16 und 30 fußball
trifft man im sportbereich 16.30 uhr
bewacht und trainiert gleichzeitig mit
den gefangenen das lenkt ab von der
langen haft und davon erneut straffällig
zu hören
das ist so eine stunde anderthalb
stunden wurde vom 8 herunter kommen
wo sich bewegen wo sie etwas für sich
tun für den körper tun man tauscht mit
anderen gefangenen aus
es wird es wurde vorher festgelegt dass
die gefangenen deutsch zu sprechen haben
hier ist
gefangener mit migrationshintergrund
auch ganz spannend vielleicht müssen die
sprache zu lernen
und dann hier wirklich nur deutsch
gesprochen werden soll aber auch den
grund weil ich beleidigung auf anderen
sprachen verstehe ich einfach nicht aber
die sich dann untereinander beleidigen
also ich würd schon ganz gerne mal
wissen wir was dir reden er spielt
manchmal sogar selbst mit dann rutscht
auch mal ein chor aus nach dem training
ist er aber wieder herr rietmann der
hier die verantwortung trägt
dass meine zeit wo wir jetzt hier
fußball anbieten dass mir keiner weg
läuft oder sie nicht aneinandergeraten
die beamtinnen und beamten in der jva
sind trotzdem unbewaffnet das hat einen
grund habe ich eine waffe an man kann
die mail adressen werden welche dann
hier dauerhaft unter woche rumlaufen und
die mit mir und rissen oder in rom habe
ich natürlich ein problem die arbeit als
sport beamter ist aber mehr als nur
aufpassen und kontrollieren durch den
dadurch dass man im sportbereich auch
ein anderes verhältnis zu den
inhaftierten aufbaut kommen die auch mit
aller art probleme dann zu 1 es ist
immer ein balance akt zwischen nähe und
distanz
die sitze nicht umsonst hier haben ging
es recht verstoßen wurden dafür bestraft
die strafe sitzen hier ab wie manche
situationen in der haft laufen wenn dann
noch kinder im spiel sind so was
kann man doch schon mal mitgefühl
aufbringen aber dass ich mitleid habe
dass sie hier sind habe ich nicht nein
kein mitleid aber viel engagement
bringen sie auf jva beamter sein
bedeutet viel mehr als nur tür auf tür
zu sie managen das haus zum teil auf das
leben der inhaftierten soll
ich musste einmal einen termin für einen
unserer gefangenen vereinbaren er klagt
über starke zahnschmerzen
übernehmen die kompletten tätigkeiten
der forte weiss besuch sei es das
reining horse buchen sei es der
arbeitseinsatz jetzt die stunden buchen
übernehmen hier die kammer die monats
bestellung bürobedarf materialbedarf
insgesamt fürs haus mit die medikamenten
bestellung mehr als nur ein job so
beschreibt es der kollege von herrn
bernd am ende gibt bernd noch zu
bedenken
ich glaube im großen ganzen kann keiner
von sich
sagen dass er noch nie mist gebaut hat
aber er wird in dem moment scheint
einfach nicht erwischt einsatz zum
nachdenken